[Music]
i have with me
david pakman he is a progressive host
an executive producer of the nationally
syndicated radio and tv program
the david pacman show and i wanted to
talk to david pacman
he is a baby
david pacman he is a
mirror david pacman
he is a beta
david pacman he is
can you remind the audience when you
talk about
being a beta male and being an alpha
male what are we talking about here
there are males most men today yeah male
1
they think and act like a woman they are
emotional
they are mentally off they have no logic
and that's a beta male they go along
with homosexuality hold on but
whoa whoa jesse well we gotta that's a
lot
that's that's raw abortion they think
and act
just like a woman a beta male died but
another baby
doesn't because he's a logical thinking
and they're controlled by the darkness
of david pacman
he is a baby
[Music]
david patman he is a baby
david pacman he is
patman he is a baby
david patman he is a baby
he gave it pacman he is
[Music]
[Music]
you're not here to communicate i really
appreciate you coming on i'm going to
let you go it's a waste of time to talk
to you
we're not communicating you're actually
like because you're asking
bizarre questions you're acting like an
idiot and you're wasting my time
i appreciate you coming
[Music]
that's a progressive vote all men
who are progressive
[Music]
all right guys yeah let's put a stop to
that because we have uh
urgent we have a lot of things going on
today this has been a very busy day
at uh david pakman show headquarters
we've uh we had uh our so let's see i
filmed our
hour-long podcast for today and the
youtube clips
usually thursdays i film the uh the
spanish language show as well which i
did
and then we had a stream earlier a press
briefing with rudy giuliani and a
variety of trump's
lawyers and it was unhinged i'm going to
have some clips for you of that
and then now we have a white house
coronavirus press briefing
we don't know who is going to show up
today
okay my i i mean listen trump may be
there he may not when they say white
house coronavirus task force sometimes
that's with trump sometimes it's without
we just really don't know at this point
and it's scheduled for 15 minutes from
now
so we'll see who we get um
and who who shows up uh but expecting
i mean i would expect it to be
extraordinarily unhinged
uh is is my uh my point of view jeremiah
just sent a hundred dollar super chat
and says courtesy of david pakman
youtube subscription upg
i am now president now with all the
biglyness i can muster i defer
all decisions to david and a team of
experts to very strongly defend the
constitution
from the standpoint of my equally bs
presidency believe me
wow jeremiah i hope that you were not
having a stroke when you wrote that
that's i love the
i love the support but i don't know what
jeremiah is talking about that's bizarre
um thanks jeremiah though i really
appreciate it
if you missed earlier you you guys have
to see this
um earlier today
um rudy giuliani it looked like he was
bleeding from his ears
during this press conference but then
when he turned sideways
i guess really what it was is his hair
dye
i guess because of gravity he must have
some kind of
spray in hair dye that as he sprays it
in as gravity takes hold
it goes down and it started leaking it
looked like blood
look at this pennsylvania michigan
wisconsin
nevada and arizona we more than double
that's crazy right and it kept going so
we're telling you is
supported by evidence
and uh we're going to have to present
let me see if i can get us a better view
of this hold on
uh rudy here it is yeah look i mean just
look at
it it looked like he was bleeding from
his ears the entire event
right up so what we're telling you is
oh god it's it's absolutely insane
that this is where we are right now um
and then i guess i haven't pre-screened
this but i guess
um they left i guess they left
some audio feed was up and you can hear
people talking about what's going on
listen i haven't heard this let's listen
all for joe biden that's like flipping a
coin
186 000 times and it lands on
[ __ ] [ __ ] rudy's hair dye dripping
down his face
there is no reasonable explanation for
the
up shoots straight
oh my god what a technical mistake
i don't even know what stream that is
but i mean
could could you could you script a more
insane
event than what took place earlier the
hot mic
i need to listen to this one more oh so
people are saying
that this was caption this was captured
from trump's official
youtube feed this is what went out on
trump's youtube feed
and at once all for joe biden that's
like flipping a coin
186 thousand times and it lands on this
[ __ ] [ __ ] rudy's hair dye dripping
down his face
there is no reasonable explanation for
the upshoots
straight lines up i'm not even it's a
comedy of errors
i mean it's just unbelievable there's no
words for what took place here
um and by the way the arguments that
they made didn't really make a lot of
sense i'll i'll play a few clips for you
guys in a little bit
um as we're standing by for who knows
what we're standing by for some kind of
update
um about the virus which is uh ravaging
the country
just to get this in the record um
yesterday 176 000 coronavirus cases
and 1974 excuse me 1974 deaths
which means we will very soon maybe even
today
be back up to 2000. we're already at a
thousand today
and some of the major states like texas
and florida and new york haven't even
reported deaths yet so we we might be
past 2 000 deaths today
as you know you know 1500 is like a 911
every two days
and we could very well be getting up to
3 000 a day which would be
like a 911 every single day trump is
checked out
trump is checked out unbelievable
um okay a few super chats coming in
barry says to put it into tv terms
america has chosen to leave it to biden
over desperate house trumps great
coverage today david
mr red says hey david want to say keep
up the great work friendly fire says
their audio was hacked by dominion
uh you you squeaking out these people
should be in prison while crying with
laughter and the last stream
set me off haven't laughed so much in
ages yeah i can get that clip
if people are interested in that let me
see here uh
twitch.tv slash david pakman
we're going to have some self-contained
let's see if i can find it so this is my
live stream which i don't want
let's go to how do i go to clips
videos um
recent highlights wow i don't even know
how to find my own clips it's so
pathetic
where are clips videos
home filter by
pass bro oh clips clips clips beautiful
uh okay yeah i think i think this is the
one
coomer i believe his name is eric patton
holders eric
coomer i believe his name is is on the
web that's too perfect
as being recorded in a conversation with
antifa
members uh saying that he had the
election
rigged for mr biden nothing to worry
about here
and he was going to they were going to i
can't take it guys
his social media is filled with hatred
for the president and for the
united states of america as a whole as
are the social media accounts of many
other smartmatic
people oh it's too much there has been
watts
okay anyway i guess that's not the right
clip but that was that was earlier it
really was a mess i mean it was i've
never seen anything like that
so that was earlier um okay
very good let me pl i'll play a couple
of clips
from the event earlier for you guys
um here's rudy explaining that a lot of
what he's saying is speculation
night seven or eight hundred thousand in
pennsylvania
somehow he lost pennsylvania we have
statisticians willing to testify
that that's almost statistically
impossible to have happened in the
period of time that it happened
but of course that's just speculation
yeah we know that's true
um julie let me see other ones that i
want to mention i just want to get to
the really crazy ones oh this is when
rudy reenacted a scene from my cousin
vinnie
probably the closest they got is from
here to the back of that room
we could do like a uh did you all watch
my cousin vinnie
did you know the movie it's one of my
favorite war movies
because he comes from brooklyn and when
the nice lady
who said she saw and then he uh
he says to her how many fingers do i how
many fingers will i got up
and she says uh three
well she was too far away to see it was
only two
these people were further away right i
mean just on the basis of that
one scene from my cousin vinnie i would
i would give the election to trump
um he talks about philly you know a lot
of padding dry
throughout the entire event uh this is
this is genius
listen to what he says in one 80 20.
so you see a change as a result of the
of that of the election in in michigan
if you take out wayne county right guys
listen wayne county has 18
of the population of the state of
michigan if you don't
count the vote from wayne county you
just remove it
trump wins michigan it's that simple
guys i mean that's pretty open and shut
um what else he lists a whole bunch of
states
a lot of this is just trash oh this was
a delusional moment when sydney powell
it sounded like a hannity monologue
take a listen to this to know right now
that we will not be intimidated
american patriots are fed up with the
corruption from the local level
to the highest level of our government
and we are going to take this country
back
from who we are not going to be
intimidated we are not going to back
down
we are going to clean this mess up it's
so fun they're acting like this
you know it's like just look at the map
guys it's like what what is trump's path
trump lost what they want to take back
is that trump lost
it's crazy now president trump won by a
landslide we're
going to prove it yeah and we're going
to reclaim the united states of america
for the
people who voted yeah so there's that um
and then the only other moment i wanted
to play for you
is uh where is it uh yeah okay so
at a certain point if you're tr whoa
look at this expression
if you're trying to convince right
wingers of a some kind of a conspiracy
you are well served to include a rich
jewish man in the conspiracy
if he's a foreigner even better and so
we eventually got to the george soros
portion of the press conference
with a company whose chairman
is a close associate and business
partner of george soros
right the biggest donor to the democrat
party
the biggest donor to antifa right the
biggest donor of black lives matter
right so anyway um you know that kind of
is like
that's how you close the loop take th
listen up kids
that is how you close the loop on and on
conspiracy theories you throw in
an anti-semitic element and then
belief in that conspiracy goes up
significantly from the right even from
some on the left i mean there's some
i'm not going to pretend there is an
anti-semitism on the left as well
although it takes a little bit of a
different
um a different form so that was earlier
like that everything we've looked at so
far was today i know it's insane but
that was all today
um let's see i did have one voicemail i
played earlier
oh for okay hold on let me not fall
behind on thank yous let me say
thanks to naom
nehem jakob is new member number one
today
and alexander nelkel is new member
number two on my website
joinpackman.com and then we are counting
uh oh my pen just collapsed
we are also counting um twitch subs of
which we've had
four which puts us at six today it's
it's all good today we're counting all
of it okay let me play i
i played this voicemail earlier we've
got a bigger audience now so let me play
this one for you this came in overnight
hey pat boy you flapping your arms
around you're gonna
fly to venezuela right why don't you
talk about the
dirty cocaine head hunter biden and his
corrupt pay-for-play father
dysfunctional father
joe don't mention that do you you
democrats don't do
anything wrong you guys are they're so
filthy i hope they get a special counsel
and i hope they
fry his ass right
the death penalty for who fry who's ass
that's bizarre
anyway so that's the type of thing
that's coming in pretty regularly
at this point and they've really ramped
up since the election
um there's been a big big ramp up since
the election and it's quite sad i mean
it's
um it's it's sad because when you you
know i i actually recorded
this is a really strong clip it's about
a 15 10 10 15 minute clip
hour long maybe three four minutes i
don't actually know how long it is
recorded it today and we'll be
publishing it later today
taking more seriously this idea of
deprogramming 75 million
people and what i think a lot of people
are forgetting is that it took
30 years to program people because the
trumpism that we're seeing today
is really the end result of what started
in the in the 80s under reagan
with these um bogus ideas of the welfare
queen you know some mom a black mom with
a cadillac and 10 kids who's living the
life on food stamps or whatever right
this was like this bogus idea of the
welfare queen from the 80s that started
with reagan
that is the trumpism today is the end
result of coalescing
that the people who fell for that and
got crazier and crazier and crazier so
if it takes 35 years to program the
people
you're not going to deprogram them in a
year you're not going to deprogram them
in even a couple of years and if you
look back in history in fact
when there have been rapid
reprogrammings
they have been authoritarian dystopias
so like one
rapid reprogramming in history was the
chinese cultural revolution under mao
zedong
and the way that they and that took a
decade
the way that china reprogrammed people
in
only 10 years was through
absolute brutal authoritarianism so you
have to understand that
and people are pointing out gingrich and
limbaugh yes all of these things check
out the book waves of rancor if you want
to understand how
uh talk radio fed off of
the reagan uh ideas of the 80s that
started a lot of this stuff you know
look
there's a lot of literature scholarly
literature on a lot of this stuff
it's going to take potentially
generational turnover as people are
pointing out that is exactly right that
is exactly right because
the only way to do it quickly is with a
brutal dictator
and that obviously would not be be a
great thing for uh
for the united states in other ways in
other ways
uh okay is is my audio cutting in and
out guys for real i
there's always like two people who claim
that they either can't see me or they
can't hear me
but everything looks fine on my end
okay yeah it's almost exclusively um
peop you know user error as like as i
like to call it
um it is funny though when people say
they can't hear or see me
because like then how do you know i'm
even on big thank you to nick
and jamie coffin kalas who are
together new member number seven today
i also want to say thanks to the three
additional twitch
subs who get us numbers eight nine and
ten i very much appreciate that
a couple of other super chats coming in
jeanette mason says if trumpet had won
this time
would he have left the white house in
four years time or would he have tried
something to keep him in there
no i that he would have left no one
programmed people in lithuania to
blindly support trump it did not take 30
years
i don't know enough about what's going
on in lithuania to be to be able to say
um but i would love to learn more about
it
we can start by insta-banning conspiracy
posts
on twitter facebook and youtube you post
conspiratorial videos or comments
instant ban yeah i mean the problem with
that is who decides
what counts um you know that's that's uh
that that's anytime you want to talk
about regulating social media who gets
to decide
and then when who's in power changes do
they just
get to impose their perspective um so
that you've got to be very careful with
that
you have to be very careful with that
thanks also to leif
westermark leif westermark is new member
number 11 today
um do i have any songs
i do have songs i don't really have
anything new
um i do still have this video
wait do i have it i have the
i'll play this i have the video of
producer pat reporting me to
trump's voter fraud line take a listen
to this
um this is i still find this very funny
i think this one will have a lot of
replay value
let me just see here hold on a second
let's shrink this down
just so everybody can see it accurately
there it is okay this is pat reporting
me take a listen
hello yes i would like to report voter
fraud today
sure what's your experience um well
there's a certain david parkman
who i know uh to have voted in nevada
um three times at least
okay and what county is that in clark
county
he goes there uh twice a year for a um
conference and also he happens to be
giving out um
borderline illegal membership discounts
right uh like 50
off 60 off 70 off and
i'm worried that that could be
sacrificing the integrity of the
election
okay and what was your name my name is
mcdonald
okay well also
within minutes of this call the entire
trump voter fraud uh reporting line was
shut down that's not a joke i mean i
think
i'm not saying that it was causally
connected
but within minutes of pat making that
phone call they said they decided they
were getting too much
um spam and prank phony phone calls
that they uh they they shut the entire
thing down so we've got
that uh yeah that's producer pat's
real affidavit that's absolutely right
donald mcronald says david love
following you through this but don't try
to find any sense with this legal fight
everything is in bad faith and a set up
for trump news like fox news
scare tactics on steroids not an
altogether crazy thing to say
yeah that certainly certainly may be
um let me see here amethyst cat
sent a 500 norwegian kroner super chat
with the message make america meow again
oh yeah i actually i got a bunch of cat
videos of cats watching
the david pakman show and reacting to it
i don't have any handy right now
unfortunately
and as far as songs go this is dj
physics in the name of jesus i think
i've only played this one once take a
listen
and secrecies and demonic plans and
networks we break
it up and we command them to be exposed
right now in the name of jesus
and strike and strike and strike and
strike and strike in the name of jesus
strike and strike until you have victory
for every enemy that is aligned against
you
[Music]
i hear a sound of shouting and singing i
hear a sound of victory
so that one goes on from there um what
else do i have
uh this is paula's deluge
[Music]
this would be like you know if you're
getting a cavity filled at the dentist
they place something light
in the background and then um here is
the song highly triggered individual
which we also love
should i play this this is one of the
most vile callers we have
take a listen to the i have not
pre-screened this so i let me just warn
you
yeah this may not be suitable for
children for children
hey little prickles now that your uh
your
hero is there are you going to sit there
in your little kimono
and wear your little hat rice
because it's going to be called no free
speech
red chinese communist speech
but you can't have pork because you
might offend the ayatollahs
after all they're going to love this too
they're going gonna make a bomb and i
hope they drop it right on your freaking
ass
but you can't have pork but you can't
have pork
but you can't have pork you like to
stick that microphone right up your ass
so anyway the musical um the musical
elements for the show continue coming in
as we are standing by here for the white
house coronavirus task force we have no
idea whether donald trump will be there
whether he won't be there it's it's
anybody's guess at this point but we're
i guess going to hear
something from someone about how great
this administration is doing at fighting
the uh fighting the coronavirus
uh okay ryan wants to know do i think
biden will deport more people than trump
did similar to how obama deported more
than trump
it's completely reasonable it's
completely
that that's absolutely a possibility
i've
you know i'm not really specially
equipped to make any kind of prediction
but i think that that's absolutely a
possibility have i seen the trump
concession speech from jimmy fallon i
did it's very funny
very funny have i seen the biden vs
trump epic rap battle i have not
that i have not seen um but i
would be interested in looking at it
maybe a little bit later
um the other question that we don't know
about
with today's press briefing is whether
they will take questions there have not
been
uh white house press secretary kaley
maggie nanny hasn't done a press
briefing
in a while hasn't taken well she showed
up as an individual last week that say
it was stolen by joe biden or something
like that
but she hasn't done a proper press
briefing and taken questions at this
point for a very very long time
um donald trump hasn't taken questions
for a long time we've not even seen
trump for a while now
and i i have no idea who's going to be
here today i have no idea if we're going
to hear from pence trump scott atlas
larry kudlow berks bricks
you know we i just don't know and um
whether they take questions is another
issue
and i don't know i hope they do because
it's time for some serious questions i
don't know why they are refusing to take
questions at this point
although i have some guesses certainly
uh
have some guesses as to why that would
be let me get to a few
other super chats that i missed um
across the board says thanks for keeping
me sane
i thought it was just me follower for
life
jackie tyt on twitter all right
um okay i already did that one
would i ever debate or have a sit down
with jimmy from philly uh
probably not let's just check that does
remind me though let's see
if we have any new voicemails from jimmy
from philly
i haven't that's on a totally different
voicemail line
let me see if we have anything
i could even check both voicemail lines
really and see what we have i might have
something for you guys
uh no
nothing from jimmy from philly for a
while
nothing there and then on our other
voicemail line
let me see here
it does look like i have
hold on a second my name is winnipeg
backway flipping your arms around the
venezuela okay flapping my arms around
venezuela i've already played for you
and okay no i guess i don't have any
other voicemails for you guys today
oh no i do i do i think i have i think
this is a troy york voicemail
yeah david pakman i like your video
about
trump attacking iran i think that's a
good idea
i think he also should attack nicholas
maduro because the role nicholas maduro
has played with the
intrusion of drugs in america and
throughout
the americas i think that
he also played a role of setting an
alliance with
the democrat party to commit the biggest
election frog
in our electoral system ever and i'd
like to see
trump in addition to bombing eye iran he
should also invade your country of
venezuela which i have i've never been
to venezuela my family's from argentina
i don't know anything about it for him
to personally deport
you as a citizen transnationalist of
venezuela
you are a propagandist from hell you are
a liar
you are a fabricator and i hope trump
departs you and you can face i'm a u.s
citizen yeah
american soldiers and try to man up and
not being that soyboy
i think that trump is really gonna
hammer it
uh because these two countries have
meddled in our
fears he's acting like trump's going to
have four more years to do stuff
it's like he's not even leaving his his
uh he's not leaving the white house this
is crazy
they have funded domestic terrorist
organizations and
insurrection in america and they have
done their part
in since 2004 the medal in our elections
much more in addition to meddling with
our mainstream media to manipulate
the viewers they have done more to
meddle in our politics than the lies
that you give about russia
does it count would this guy could be
considered to be maulding is that
an accurate is that the right use of the
term guys in 2016 and for three years
you attempted
to fraudulently dethrone our great
president donald trump
he stands in the way of the globalist
desire to destroy the dollar
as glenn beck says and to uh glenn beck
basically
he's the only thing standing up to the
globalists
and people by the way doesn't the term
dethrone not make sense when it's a
president and not a king well such as
yourself for total control
you are the epitome of evil you are an
enemy agent of nicholas maduro
you are a d guys i'm against the madu
how many times do i have to say
that i am against the maduro regime i
don't like it
i don't think the u.s should be involved
in any way down there but i am not a
maduro guy
you are a pale ghost danger to society
and i hope that trump sends in the full
forces and creates
total chaos and warfare perhaps a world
war against those who would manipulate
interfere with our elections and i think
trump is going to come for people like
you trump's got nine weeks guys what are
you talking about
pacman you have propagandizing lied and
you've been a domestic
agent and terrorist all this time right
and i think you might want to uh
prepare yourself for the eventual
overthrow and warfare
which bends away like your native land
i've never been to venezuela i have
nothing to do with venezuela what a
bizarre voicemail right
um very very strange stuff let's briefly
see what kamal is saying president-elect
biden and i
will make sure you have the resources
and support you need
to save lives and help get our economy
back on track
and we will also make sure that our
federal state local and tribal
authorities
are working closely together so we can
tackle these challenges
as effectively as possible because when
it comes to this pandemic
and the economic recovery we are not
democrats
or republicans we are americans
and we will be there for one another
that's the kind of leadership
the american people need and deserve and
it's the kind of leadership
president-elect biden and i will provide
and it is now my great honor to
introduce
president-elect joe biden
so we will keep an eye on the white
house press briefing it would be
amazing if uh we could watch all of this
first that that i think would be
interesting i don't know if joe biden is
pausing for a little
sanitizing they are oh bringing in the
sanitizer moving the
binder and uh joe biden
waiting patiently for that nicely done
hello folks
good afternoon thank you for your
patience oh boy
the vice and president as just as
pointed out
have uh just concluded a video
conference
with the executive leadership at the
national governor's conference
they included governor cuomo new york
governor hutchinson
governor hogan governor whitmer governor
ivey governor
polis governor baker governor
lujan grisham governor herbert and
governor carney
and it was really a worthwhile
undertaking you know uh they've had to
make
some really tough calls during this
unprecedented crisis
and we're incredibly grateful for
everything they've done and
keep doing to try to keep their
communities safe
unfortunately because of the lack of
assertment as they say which is that's a
fancy word these days but until the
head of the gsa says that we in fact
our team this transition team our team
this the senator and i have in fact are
the likely winners
until she does that we don't have access
to all the information
that we need to get from all the various
agencies imagine that we're not able to
deal with everything from testing the
guidance to the
all-important issue of vaccine
distribution and even more importantly
vaccination plan to actually get
vaccinations
we haven't been able to get into
operation warp speed
but we will take what we've learned
today and build it into our planning
the country is still in a crisis and
there's a dark winter still ahead
yesterday america reached another tragic
milestone
200 000 deaths
a quarter of a million people died due
to cover 19.
and there are empty chairs and dining
room tables just
were filled just days and weeks ago
with loved ones family friends who
laughed and talked together
to those families and friends that are
left behind
jill and i send our our love and our
prayers
we know like many of you do how tough it
is to
find purpose in the memory of a loved
one you've just lost
it'll take time but you'll find it
you'll find it
and we'll and you'll find your purpose
as we're going to find our purpose
for our nation as a nation now i promise
you that
and i promise you that we'll work
together there's a
there's a great meeting we had today all
the governors no matter their political
party
whether they're from wherever part of
the country they represent it
no matter their political philosophy
shared a strong
and abiding sense of a common purpose
there was a real desire
for a real partnership between the
states and the federal government
each of the governors emphasized that we
might be democrats
republicans but we're all americans
first
they congratulated us heartily for the
the
our win what really pleased me was the
most was that governors made clear that
beating covet 19 is going to require
all of us working together as one
country imagine that
kamal and i agree we are we were deeply
impressed with how much consensus there
was
how to move forward among the governors
what we need to do now
is how we need to do it how are we going
to do it
in what coordinated way can it be done
we discussed a number of critical ways
we can work together
and unify around a national approach to
controlling covet 19.
first delivering economic relief to the
city-states and tribal communities
the lost revenue from covet and the cost
of cover recovery is
devastating to state and local budgets
as governors
as all of them indicated we've got to
come together
the federal government has to deliver
this release
sooner rather than later and with
flexibility for the states to meet their
needs
this includes helping businesses schools
working families
from unemployment benefits to early
education continued access to affordable
health care
all of that's needed during this
pandemic states and communities
shouldn't have to lay off teachers
cops firefighters cut vital services for
families and businesses
the second thing there was uniform
agreement on delivering a safe
and equitable and free vaccine
the governors all acknowledged that
there will be a massive undertaking
one of the greatest operational
challenges we will have faced as a
nation
one statistic that was raised by the
governors
it took eight months to provide
100 million covet tests eight months
to provide covetes just imagine how much
more difficult will be they pointed out
if we don't find a more efficient and
effective way
to provide 330 million vaccinations
it in perspective they made the point we
can't wait
that's what the governors are raising in
the media we discussed the challenges
that lie ahead
in distributing and administering the
vaccine
the governor's talked about how getting
doses of vaccine distributed
is just one step we have to actually get
vaccinations into the arms of 330
million americans that takes enormous
resources
people product we discuss the difficulty
of that task it's going to take time
it's going to take coordination it's
going to take the federal government and
state governments working
hand in glove working together governor
the governor's all emphasized we need to
be clear with the american people
about what to expect no false
expectations let them know what we
anticipate
they all acknowledge that this is going
to take a massive public education
campaign
and we also need to reach traditionally
underserved communities
that are being hard to sit by the
pandemic black brown latino latin
american community native american
communities
small towns rural communities they
talked about that in some detail
thirdly just to catch people up so joe
we did not know this was happening joe
biden is speaking a little bit about his
conference call with
governors on coronavirus we're also
standing by for a trump press briefing
this is the first time i've ever seen a
sign language interpreter
during one of these with the trump
administration and this is something joe
biden has been doing now for a little
while
it really seems like they're just
copying it
it's interesting correct me if i'm wrong
guys but i don't think that we
saw that before uh but we are standing
by
there and um let's go back to joe biden
for a bit
our view is that should be done when it
comes to deploying the national guard or
covert or real relief
that should be paid for you know that's
something kamalai will be very focused
on
and fourthly we discussed the
implementation
of a national mass mandate ten governors
wow democrat and republican have imposed
masking requirements
and recognized the need for universal
masking north south east and west
is not a political statement it's a
patriotic duty
wow and fifth we discussed
making testing more available and
accessible
anyone who wants a test should be able
to get one period
and finally while we focused on the
immediate needs to control the virus the
governor's also raised and talked about
how much we have to build back better
especially on infrastructure
and education and so much more
this is not a one-off meeting i
committed we committed
we agreed that we'll continue to work
and meet with the governors
on a regular basis sounds like they're
going to do stuff their input
and that our covet teams will follow up
and coordinate
on the issues coming out of that call
because some of them have
very competent people on their covet
teams in their states
the bottom line we can do this
there's nothing beyond our capacity but
we have to come together as a country
what this meeting along with others
we've had reinforces in my view
is the unity the country is looking for
they're looking for us to come together
and deal with problems most of which
have no ideological basis
for disagreement that's what we have to
do
that's what the governors talked about
it really was pleasing to hear them
i want to thank you all and may god
bless you all those who lost someone
you're in our prayers
may god protect our troops i'm happy to
take a few questions
and my boss is going to tell me who that
is
uh thank you mr president-elect
i know you mentioned the economic impact
and talked a bit about the relief
package you wanted
but i was wondering if we could talk
about things that you'll be able to do
just as president or what will sort of
govern your decision
uh in terms of the economy so i was
wondering if i could ask
what kind of framework you're thinking
about as you decide about a treasury
secretary
going forward whether you would consider
you had said during the debates that you
wanted to punish china over the way that
they've been acting
whether that could include economic
sanctions or tariffs towards china
and finally do you think a strong dollar
helps or hurts
the us as we're grappling with historic
unemployment
well look uh let me try to take him one
at a time we're soon here my choice for
treasury i made that decision we've made
that decision
wow can you hear that he's already made
it either just before just after
thanksgiving
number one and you'll find it is someone
who uh
i think is uh will be accepted by all
elements of the democratic party
elements aggressive to the moderate uh
coalitions
uh secondly um uh it's not so much about
punishing china it's about making sure
china understands they got to play by
the rules
it's a simple proposition and so that's
one of the reasons why
we're going to rejoin the world health
organization we're going to rejoin
on day one as well and it needs reform i
acknowledge
and rejoin the paris climate accord
and we have to make sure that the rest
of the world
and we get together and make sure there
are certain bright lines chinese
understand
we have to not only deal with this
pandemic but a plan for the next one
the idea that viruses are going to go
away is just not rational
we're going to re we're going to
recalibrate and set up the
the institute we the institutional
structures we had
in our administration of obama biden and
build on it
and what was your third question it was
about the dollar sir whether you think a
strong dollar
will help for her with unemployment or
generally just how you'd like the
federal reserve to
sort of approach the well quite frankly
the way the federal reserve
has been approaching uh uh the uh
uh dealing with the dollar has i think
has been
in a positive direction our interest
rates are as low as they have been
in modern history uh and i think that is
a positive thing it lends
credence to the possibility of us being
able to
expend the money and deficit spend in
order to be able to generate economic
growth
right off the bat and so i think it's
been positive so far
thank you i think you just answered
three questions
i mean you know thank you mr
president-elect
you have said that if this transition
doesn't get going especially
coordination on vaccine distribution
that lives will be lost how many lives
do you think are at risk here if
i think he just pulled out a seating
chart of the media we've you you've
heard the projections the projections
are
that if nothing fundamentally changes
between now
and uh beginning of february we're gonna
to lose up to 400 total of 400 thousand
lives another 150 000 lives
and so it's real whether it's that it
gets to 360 whatever it is it's real
and there is no excuse not to
share the data and let us begin to plan
because on day one it's going to take us
time if we don't have access to all this
data
it's going to put us behind the eight
ball by a matter of a month or more
and that's lives how many would be lost
as a consequence of that i can't tell
you
but the purpose here is to get we talked
a lot about what the governor's about
what the immediate needs are i'm going
to we're going to impose the we're going
to enforce the
excuse me employ the defense uh
reconstruct the act
to be able to go out there and dictate
companies build and do following things
we need much more testing we need much
more masking i mean that's more we need
gloves what did he just say that was
weird i don't know what he just said
national governor association through
the governor
cuomo and the ones on the line to let us
know what their shortages are what they
anticipate
because we're going to move on day one
that should be moved on now
now but if it waits it takes a long time
to get this thing going
and when you take a step back and you
look at the way the president is
handling this his refusal to concede
what do you think is really going on
here in your view
mr president-elect what do you think the
president is doing what are
americans witnessing here
let me choose my words oh here uh
i think they're witnessing incredible
irresponsibility
incredibly damaging messages being sent
to the rest of the world about how
democracy functions
and i think it is uh
well i don't know his motive but i i
just think it's totally irresponsible
are you concerned you may succeed hey
guys we're not controlling the ads on
twitch
we're not putting any ads in i'm not
concerned the vast majority of the
american people they've already all the
polling data has indicated although the
republicans who
worry about it it's higher but the over
78 of the american people believe it's
without question it's legitimate um
and uh i just think it's uh and i think
most of the republicans i've spoken to
including
the governors think this is debilitating
it's not a
it sends a horrible message about who we
are as a country
thank you mr president-elect thank you
president vice president-elect harris
appreciate it
nice to see you as well yes appreciate
it
um you have said that lives could be
lost if you don't
start getting briefings from the trump
administration and now here we are more
than 250
000 lives could be lost given that
how do you justify not taking legal
action
to get the briefings that you say are
critical that you say you need
it would take a lot of time take it
would take time
it's not going to speed it up
considerably in my view and in the
meantime
i i'm hopeful that
i'm going to be able to get cooperation
from our republican colleagues in the
senate in the house as well as
on the governors to build a consensus of
how we proceed when we do
but why not use every tool in your
toolbox to get the information that
you say you need to do your job i see a
lot of people confused we're still
waiting on the
on the trump coronavirus briefing um
it hasn't started yet it's very late and
we're with joe biden right now
my judgment is that it is
we'll get further along by
actually
working with our republican colleagues
now and because the time in which we
would win would not
materially change necessarily but it's
still an open question it's an open
question it could change
so you haven't ruled it out you haven't
ruled out legal action against the trump
administration against the gsa
we haven't ruled it out okay and given
the death toll now more than 250 000
americans who have now lost their lives
you have said that
you would support a nationwide shutdown
if scientists recommended it
no you've spoken you got to stop using
that word everybody asks that question
every single time i stand here it was a
hypothetical question
the answer was i would follow the
science i am not going to shut down the
economy
period i'm going to shut down the virus
that's what i'm going to shut down so
that's why
again no national shutdown
no national shutdown wow because
every region every area every community
is can be different and so there's no
circumstance which i can see
would require a total national shutdown
i think that would be counterproductive
but
there are constraints in which
shouldn't he be attacking the reporter
as nasty open for example
it's one thing to say that you can have
uh
in a state that is there where their
infection rate is not as high you can
have a
gymnasium open it's another thing to say
it can only be open four hours a day
with x number of people
the church i go to my catholic church
they don't allow more than forty percent
of the people
are uh to come into the church those are
rational decisions
with masks it's calibrating based on
what the what the threat is
thank you mr president
thank you mr vice president elect
thank you mr president-elect and vice
president elect harris
for you first which is what do you make
of the fact that the president
is having these calls with michigan
county officials um amid his bid to
overturn
the election he's going to be having
also michigan republican legislators at
the white house tomorrow
anything that he's doing making you
rethink your strategy i know you say
that you don't want to have legal action
right now and what do you say to
americans especially
immigrant americans who came to the
united states looking for political
stability and seeing
all the things that the president is
doing
hang on i'm on my way that's what i say
to them
not a joke and what the president's
doing now is uh is really
um
it's going to uh
be another incident where he will go
down in history
as being one of the most irresponsible
presidents in american history
wow it's it's just
out of the not even within the norm at
all
there's questions whether it's even
legal but uh
it's going to be interesting who shows
up
uh in this call to meet with the
leadership
and uh but um this is going to
we we've won michigan it's going to be
certified we're going to end up
making clear that they are
making clear that we want and uh
but it just uh i i just
come on guys how this man thinks
it's hard to fathom
i i'm confident he knows he hasn't won
and is not going to be able to win and
we're going to be sworn into january
20th
and i just uh you know but
far for me to question his motive it's
just it's just outrageous what he's
doing
but as he as he ups the things that he's
doing calling officials is it making you
rethink your strategy at all
is there anything that he would be doing
that would make you say okay we really
have to go to court now
or are you still watching what he's
doing and saying we can still
kind of wait and see what happens
i i'm not going to rule anything out or
anything in
but at the moment the strategy is not
it's not changing
and if i could ask a question to the
vice president-elect with that sure
um vice president-elect harris you
talked about your state
um your state experience my question is
is there anything that you heard from
governors today
that made you specifically concerned
about vulnerable populations
especially as i talked to americans who
say i don't have the privilege to work
from home i don't have the privilege
to social distance if i'm living in a
house with multi-generations are
you did you hear anything um that
concerns you specifically
and what can we do for them as a country
well as the president-elect
shared with with everyone we heard a lot
from the governors including that um
including the concern that uh
african-americans latinos native
americans
people who live in rural communities uh
people who
as as groups of people have historically
been
under resourced and underserved and so
there was consensus among the
the governor's bipartisan consensus that
our federal strategy
should reflect those concerns in a way
that we support the states with the
resources they'll need
to get to the folks who have been often
overlooked or ignored
and the president-elect i think has made
it very clear that it's one of
our highest priorities to support that
as you may know in the senate
i actually led what we call the racial
disparities task force
and that approach is something that we
will be incorporating in our
administration
to ensure that all people have equal
access to resources
but also taking it into account
equitable distribution of resources
based on need
thank you president-elect one important
thing to understand is there is a
and we've talked a lot about this and we
talked about it i talked about it when i
was running seeking the nomination as
well
and that is that the idea of the
brown black uh
asian american native american
communities
are always the first ones hit the
hardest and the last ones
who are brought back we're going to flip
that around
it's going to be really important to
determine priorities
based upon access to the information
that's available access to everything
from
the vaccine to other
opportunities to be able to deal with
helping the country part of the country
hurt the worst
you know three times as many
african-americans have died than
white americans died from copen so there
has to be
a prioritization that's what i'd like to
know exactly what this
uh well what this administration has in
mind in terms of their operation warp
speed and
how they plan it and that's what we
talked about with the governors today
they all mentioned the need to focus on
communities have been left behind
particularly governor cuomo
it's one thing if for example vaccines
have distributed all the walgreens of
america i'm not
no criticism of walgreens but you know
there's a lot of those facilities that
aren't in
rural communities and are not in poor
communities african-american latino
countries that's a real issue so we've
got to make sure there's access for them
thank you so much
okay thank you
all right
so there is joseph r biden jr uh
president-elect joe biden
with uh just kind of a calm event i mean
he just took questions essentially
we're now standing by for the trump
white house coronavirus
task force press briefing we don't know
who's going to come out
trump might be here he might not pence
maybe dr scott atlas a radiologist maybe
maybe they'll bring out a podiatrist
maybe they'll bring out a dentist we
don't know
who's going to come out but um people
will be
saying things and we we will be
listening
let me take this a brief interlude
just to mention i would really love it
i would really love it if you grabbed
yourself a membership on my website
joinedpakman.com as many of you know
we were 100 demonetized by facebook last
week
for talking about something steve bannon
said we have now regained
partial monetization uh on facebook
at no point did we have any contact with
anybody at facebook these things are
very
irregular they're like a very bad ekg uh
or even an okay one i guess i mean you
know
is sort of up down to a normal ekg as
well but in any case
i would love it if you grabbed a
membership at joinedpakman.com it's our
primary funding source it's our most
direct funding source it's not a lot of
money and we control the system
completely
um and we have this coupon code fresh
start
which will save you an ungodly amount of
money just a crazy amount of money you
save with the coupon code don't feel
obligated to use it but it is available
it's not
means tested or anything like that you
will also notice here oh so literally it
does look like they were literally
waiting for the
biden event to end so we've got azar
and uh you know various
people there's the general who
sycophantically praised
trump the other day um so this is going
to be a mess also notice now that
they seem to have brought in a sign
language interpreter which they didn't
do at any point during these
i i think they started because they saw
biden doing it during his events
i can't think of any other reason why
they are doing it the sign language
interpreter sort of looks like that
right wing reporter
mary katherine hamm interestingly enough
i don't think it's her
and maybe i'm wrong that it's a sign
language interpreter i don't know
but that's what i think is going on here
so we're going to be standing by
is it going to be pence is it going to
be atlas magnani
i've i have no no idea who we're going
to be
hearing from um i see the super chats
have been coming in and i i do
appreciate them
let me just see here i want to get us an
update oh is that fouchy
no way they brought fouchy back they're
desperate oh my god
they're completely desperate if they're
bringing in fouchy
is that dick cheney who's that guy
if fauci's here it is unhinged let me
say
oh he should be here it's just shocking
that they brought him in after
the very public battle he'll soon be
working for joe biden
an additional 12 folks have signed up
putting us at 23
and also 10 more twitch subs which puts
us
at 33. so i think that that gets me
completely caught up this is just what i
mean like
if after all this fauci suddenly
reappears as joe biden is getting ready
to take over
uh and it looks like pence only with a
mask they
wow joe biden being president-elect has
really impacted them huh
well good afternoon
[Music]
we just completed our second meeting
this week with members of the white
house coronavirus task force
and we've continued we've continued to
be on the same mission we've been on
throughout the course of this year and
that is to save american lives
to work every day toward that day that
we put the coronavirus
in the past i'm joined today and you'll
hear in a few moments from members of
the white house coronavirus task force
including those that are
leading the effort of distribution
uh vaccinations under operation warp
speed
and i think you will be as impressed as
i was
at fema earlier today when i heard the
detailed plans
for the virtually immediate distribution
of vaccines when they become approved
and
available these guys are desperate huh
from very early in this pandemic
at the president's direction we have
followed an approach
to this pandemic that was federally
supported state managed and
locally executed and to that end this
past monday we completed
our 41st conference call with all of the
nation's governors every state
every territory there we spoke about uh
our current circumstances where we see
cases and hospitalizations rising but we
also continue to speak to them
about uh about the expansion of testing
the availability of supplies and our
ongoing
efforts to continue to drive forward
toward the development and the
distribution
of a vaccine for the american people as
we gather here today
with cases and hospitalizations rising
across the country
president trump directed us to host this
briefing
to describe the ongoing work different
task force and our
partnership with state and local
officials and our partners in the
private sector to continue to put the
health
of america first but first let me begin
simply by saying that our hearts and our
prayers
are with all of those families that have
been impacted
by the coronavirus over the course of
the past 10 months
and let me say personally not a day has
gone by
that i haven't thought personally about
families that have lost loved ones and i
want to assure each of you that
you will always be in our hearts and you
will remain in our prayers
but we wanted to take this opportunity
also to thank the american people
for the extraordinary sacrifices that
you've made
over the course of the past 10 months
we've been through a lot together
and we went through 45 days to slow the
spread back
when the positivity rate across this
country was more than 20 percent
we managed to accomplish our objective
uh we slowed the spread we flattened the
curve they accomplished their ability
then during the outbreak across the sun
belt this summer when we saw
positivity rise to nearly 10 percent the
american people
officials at the federal and state level
stepped up again
and we put that outbreak in the past
and even as we see help on the way
vaccines being developed at a historic
pace
as i mentioned before as we gather today
we are seeing
cases and positivity rising across the
country
but we approach this moment with the
confidence of experience
we know the american people know what to
do
we have forged a partnership that is
truly seamless with state
and local health authorities and as
we'll describe you today
we've continued to work seven days a
week all throughout this year and up to
this very moment
to make sure the american people have
access to the health care that we'd want
any member of our family
to have as we meet this pandemic now
cases are rising throughout the country
positivity in the last 30 days has risen
from an average of five percent
uh to 10 and uh
to that end we've uh continued the
mobilization that began
at president trump's direction early
this year we increased testing
from a standing start in the month of
february to now as of today we've
completed more than 170 million tests
and we continue to approve newton's
imagine still talking about the number
of tests over the last 10 months
it's we're distributing more than 150
million by next test to
to schools and nursing homes around
america as we speak
uh our mobilization of supplies you will
hear described in great detail
continues to surge each and every day we
actually are able
to track ppe and supplies on a
hospital-by-hospital basis
and so we're carefully monitoring we're
working with state officials
with hospital administrators to make
sure that our hospitals have the support
they need
also as we gather more than 140 clinical
trials for therapeutics continue to be
underway but effective therapies are
already available
that are widely known among the american
people and for those
over the age of 70 we're proud to report
that we actually have decreased
the fatality rate by more than 70
percent
uh since those remember that the
fatality rate goes down when you do more
tests interestingly enough and so
you really want to look at the infection
fatality rate you guys already know how
they mess with you guys with these
numbers focusing on accelerating the
development
the manufacture and the distribution of
a safe and effective
vaccine and you'll have an update today
on the progress from
two of our leading experts and those
that are coordinating operation warp
seed
what i want to say in the midst of all
of this to the american people as we
begin
this briefing say something is that
with the with the massive increase in
testing over the last 10 months
with ppe and medical supplies and
equipment that are available to the
american people
with the medicines and the therapeutics
and very soon the vaccines that are
available
america has never been more prepared to
combat this virus
than we are today our pledge to each and
every we were more prepared the day
obama left actually with the pandemic
response team and the playbook
make sure that hospitals that are seeing
patients coming in
on an increasing basis know that we're
gonna we're gonna work around the clock
to meet that need
and you have our continuing pledge and
the practice of experience that we've
had along the way
so in a few moments you'll hear from
members of our team we're going to begin
with dr deborah burks who's going to
describe what we're seeing in
rising cases literally every day
for members of the task force begins
with detailed analysis
of what's happening across the country
and she'll give you our very best
our very best information on rising
cases and hospitalizations
that information is summarized each and
every week for the nation's governors
and provided to them
in particular detail as well after dr
burke speaks we've asked
general david sanford with fema to
provide an update on our ongoing efforts
to provide
ppe and medical supplies to our
uh hospital needs we're we're literally
going to make sure as i said that uh as
we see cases rising that we're
we're meeting the needs and hospitals
okay
to stand up the response that any one of
us would want a family member to be able
to have access to
then we've asked dr fauci to give us an
update on the
historic progress on the development of
they're going to let thousands
it's they're acting like it's normal
that fouchy's here every couple of days
that's great like trump hasn't said
fauci's out of his mind
general gus perna will outline our
distribution plans
on operation warp speed i was at fema
today
received a detailed brief briefing about
our distribution plan we got detailed
belief
and i asked general general perna to
come here today
to make that presentation and to the
american people and
uh and it is in a very real sense um
putting us in a position that literally
the day after one of these vaccines is
approved we'll be shipping
vaccines to the american people and
within a day after that
uh we'll be seeing those vaccines
injected right
into americans with a particular focus
on those most vulnerable and
and those that are providing health care
to the american people
uh finally uh we'll we'll talk with uh a
bit about
uh the way forward as state and local
government the different president
are continuing to act and take
mitigation measures to slow the spread
there's no way they take questions right
we can assure them as we did governors
again this week that we'll support
decision making at the local level and
we'll continue to support decisions that
are made
in each individual community based on
the circumstances on the ground
but that being said president trump
wanted me to make it clear that
our task force this administration and
our president does not support another
national lockdown
and we do not support closing schools
you'll hear from dr robert redfield of
the cdc that
actually the cdc never recommended that
we close schools
this year and dr eleanor mccann's katz
uh who's also serves with substance
abuse and mental health services
at hhs will describe the real cost to
children being away from school
but in every one of these cases we're
going to give you the best information
that we have sounds like this will be
three hours long
i just want to assure the american
people as i trust that you will
have a sense today that we're going to
continue to work around the clock
to meet this moment but help is on the
way we have every confidence in
10 months in help is coming soon we
could have one or more
safe and effective vaccines for the
american people
and as each of us does our part in
partnership with state and local
officials
each of us does our part to look after
our own families and our own communities
i believe the day is coming soon when we
will put this coronavirus in the past
and the day when he leaves dr deborah
burks who will update us on
cases and after that after that we will
get a
presentation on the availability of
supplies
that we continue to make available this
show that they're putting on today is
actually stunning i mean it's amazing
they've
decided to put this on now now 11 months
in
however long and it's really a moment
that we want to call on every american
to increase their vigilance
um and i want to go through some data
about why we are asking people from elko
nevada
through denver colorado to philadelphia
from madison wisconsin to el paso texas
and across this great nation to really
increase their vigilance at this moment
i want to thank the governors and mayors
and county commissioners
that i've had the privilege to talk to
over the last four and a half months of
being on the road
we can have the first slide please the
number of universities
42 states 30 universities and
a large number of chairmen from our
tribal nations
the reason we wanted to really be and
here is to really understand the reality
on the ground what they were facing and
understand how we could be more
supportive
and this is really a call it's almost a
real surreal now to have this it's like
where have you guys been the last six
months now they're active
they're pretending like they've been
doing this stuff all along and wearing
masks and
it's crazy urge the summer surge and the
fall search
so the american people know that this is
more cases more rapidly than what we had
seen before
but to also make it clear like before we
do know what to do
and we're asking every american to do
those things today
the next slide shows our increase in
test positivity
the light brown bars are the number of
tests that were performed
but even with the number and ever
increasing number of tests performed you
can see the increase in test positivity
to around 10 percent yeah in some areas
of the country
it is much higher than that and it
illustrates the ongoing community spread
in your counties in your small and large
metros
and in your rural areas the next slide
really shows the country as a whole
and why we're asking every american to
remain vigilant
to do those things that we have been
asking you all to do
to wear a mask upper midwest physically
distance
the continuer hand hygiene but really
in this moment of bringing people
together
to really limit interactions
indoors to immediate households when we
see this level
of community spread behind this level of
community spread
is a lot of asymptomatic cases
people are spreading the virus because
they don't know they're infected with
the virus
and so people are coming together
indoors everyone looks healthy
but among those individuals could be
individuals that
already are infected have no symptoms
and are unknowingly spreading the virus
to others
it is because of this asymptomatic
spread that we have asked people to wear
masks
indoors and to ask people to wear masks
when among others
but sometimes when we go indoors and
we're with friends and family
we just assume that if you look okay you
are okay
and now we know that over 50 of the
individuals particularly among those
under 35
many could be infected and unknowingly
spreading the virus
this virus increased so rapidly because
there was an unusual cold snap that
began in the northern plains and went
down through the heartland
where in the end of september beginning
october a large number of people moved
indoors
so we've been going across the country
to really tell them that a linux
atlanta mid-atlantic states and the
northeast
to really increase testing looking for
these asymptomatic
cases and i really want to thank the
governors across this great land who
have
really heeded that call and set up what
we call sentinel populations whether
it's nursing home staff
k-12 teachers whether it's community
college students
county workers specific businesses to
really have routine weekly testing so
that we can see the spread of this virus
down to the zip code
and really combat that with additional
mitigation
the next slide shows what we have been
talking about about the level of
hospitalization
it's much better without trump there
have you guys noticed hospitalizations
by the darkness of the color and i just
want to make it
clear what the vice president talked
about we now can see
every admission every day and i want to
thank the hospitals who from july have
been sending us that data and improving
that data and working with cdc
so that we can see new admissions we can
see inpatient status we can see ccu
icu status and we can see who's being
admitted by age group
right now it's about 50 50 between those
between
40 and 69 and those over 70.
but you can see that we have some areas
of the country in the hot
red bright pink and these are the
darkest red or those
states that have more than 21 percent of
their hospitals are covet patients
and the light pink is between 16 and 20
percent
and the light orange between 12 and 15
but you do see that they're still states
in the green areas and to all of those
states
that have not seen this surge to really
increase your testing among
asymptomatics by setting up these
sentinel populations
when we did the 45 days to
stop the spread and we asked each state
to follow the grading criteria
part of that gating criteria included
looking for asymptomatic cases with
these new antigen tests we have the
capacity
to really expand testing to find those
cases and stop that spread
in the meantime as we started with
we stop the surge in the south through
very
targeted mitigations that start with
mass
that start with physical distancing but
also
include decreasing those friends and
family gatherings
where people come together and
unknowingly spread the virus
and i want to thank the mayors of miami
miami city and miami county
who they were the ones that first in the
summer really found
how much asymptomatic spread was
occurring in household gatherings
and so as you bring together individuals
remember what the vice president talked
about
every american needs to be vigilant in
this moment
because we know that when you are we can
mitigate this virus and stop this spread
together
now obviously if they had been doing
this since march we'd be better off
with particularity on a state-by-state
basis we
want the american people to know that we
have we have eyes on your local hospital
we know about admissions we know about
the availability of icu beds and we know
about supplies
and from very early on at the
president's direction we stood up the
greatest national mobilization since
world war
ii and i want the american people to
know that that continues
to this moment and uh general david
sanford
who's been with us every step of the way
is going to
brief you on the status of our supply
chain
and uh the reserves that we have and our
ongoing efforts to make sure that our
our hospitals and healthcare facilities
have the resources and the support
to meet this moment general
mr vice president thank you sir dr burks
thank you ma'am
so we are in a much better place and
continue to improve upon that capability
you'll see from the slides behind me
that we have
continued to grow our national stockpile
but also our fema stocks
to meet the requirements laid out by our
states and by our populations
we continue to expand upon these to
bridge
the vaccine delivery to continue to
protect
our american population since the late
summer we have grown our personal
protective equipment capabilities
10 to 15 times over what they were
pre-coded
and can continue to grow capability to
meet the surge requirements that we may
expect
from the current it's great to have
masks but i don't know that i'd say
we're in a good place right now
fourth column we have four months of
surge capability
based on current current case diagnosis
just for n95 masks and we continue to
grow that capability more mass being
added
every month the strategic national
stockpile and our fema
stocks are ready to be the backstop when
our states
require assistance and that's all built
upon a foundation
of a strong domestic medical industrial
base
something where we've been able to
expand upon or build in some cases
almost from scratch
using our defense production act and
other cares act authorities
to provide the capabilities for our
american people not just
now but into the future and for future
crisis or medical events going down
we go next slide please this is not done
alone we continue to work with our
states
on a recurring basis our fema
administrator is constantly engaged with
the governors
or their staffs we reach out to both our
regional administrators
to the state medical or health
department officials
and both to the emergency management
officials in the state to find out what
their needs are to help overcome their
challenges
and to grow the state's stockpiles as
that relates to our
federal emergency management mandate of
local execution state management federal
support
as you saw in the previous slide and as
you'll see on on this color-coded map
between our states and the federal
government we stand in a much better
position than we were
just a month ago and certainly more than
four or five months ago
uh to meet the surging ppe demands
of our of our nation and this is not
something that we're we're sitting and
continuing just to watch it is something
that we're continuing to grow upon
and continuously analyze so that we can
stay ahead
of the increases and make sure that
we're either procuring
and we have a ppe on the on the way
to meet the surging cases
i'll turn it over to dr fauci and
general perna all right
fauci makes his return after being
slandered by trump
with that i'm going to invite dr tony
fauci to come up and
share his thoughts on the development of
a vaccine which is giving such great
hope
but i i trust uh that the panels that
you just showed us
uh encourage the american people i think
fouchy's double mask
we're going to continue to work around
the clock to make sure your local
hospital
has the resources and supplies that you
need
to meet this moment but i think we all
know that we ultimately put this
pandemic in the past the day that we
have a safe and effective vaccine
we've been making historic progress
through operation warp speed with our
private partners
uh and dr tony fauci and nih just let
you speak
dude come on best dr fatchi to update
you on the status of vaccine development
and then uh and then we will have
general gus perna who is coordinating
the distribution
plan for operation warp speed working
with every state and territory in
america to be ready
on day one to distribute vaccines as
soon as they're available to give you a
brief outline
on that plan so dr fauci
thank you very much mr vice president uh
as i was sitting there i was recalling
that
about seven or eight months ago i warned
all you [ __ ] about this exact
spot at a time when there was really an
extraordinary
surge in cases in the northeastern part
of the country
in new york city and i said that if the
virus was left to its own devices it
would cause
a considerable degree of devastation
because that's what pandemic
viruses do it's a very powerful force
and you've heard about that and what we
need to do about it
from dr burks however i also said if
some of you can remember
that there's an opposing force to that
and that opposing force
is us you and i being able to do
certain things like mitigation with
public health measures
again which was just mentioned by dr
burks
but there's another opposing force to
that and that's a vaccine
and historically if you look at highly
efficacious and effective
vaccines through the years they've
crushed
formidable outbreaks like smallpox
like polio like measles so in the next
couple of minutes let me tell you about
what we have now and what's going to
happen
in the next few months please as you
well know operation warp speed has been
supporting directly and indirectly six
candidate vaccines
four of which are either in or completed
phase three clinical trial i want to
briefly tell you about two of them
because you have to be interested in
this
it is extraordinarily impressive two of
the vaccines one by moderna and one
by the company pfizer have completed
trials
and the f and the efficacious
vaccine efficacy point is extraordinary
with regard to pfizer it was 95 percent
efficacious not only against disease
that's just clinically
recognizable disease but severe disease
there were ten cases of severe disease
one in the vaccine nine in the placebo
for the moderna trial it was 94.5
percent
efficacious 11 severe events
zero in the vaccine 11 in the placebo
strong for those of you not acquainted
with the field of vaccinology
that is extraordinary that is almost to
the level
of what we see with measles which is 98
effective
so that's what we're dealing with the
question is
what about how that is going to be
rolled out
i use the word efficacious that means
what happens in a clinical trial
the word effective means is what the
ultimate impact
of that vaccine is going to be on
society do people get it the only way
you can get
an effective program is when people take
the vaccine
and we're going to be talking to you
about that and i hear a lot now when we
made these announcements this past
monday
and then two mondays ago about some
reticence of people well did you rush
this was this too
fast is it really safe and is it really
efficacious
the process of the speed did not
compromise at all
safety nor did it compromise scientific
integrity
it was a reflection of the extraordinary
scientific advances
in these types of vaccines which allowed
us to do things in months
that actually took years before wow so i
really want to settle that concern
that people have about that what about
the decision
of the data who looked at the data was
that some
force that was maybe trying to put
something over on you
no it was actually an independent body
of people who have no allegiance to
anyone not to the administration
not to me not to the companies that
looked at the data and deemed it to be
sound
now that data will be examined very
carefully by the fda
who together with a advisory committee
the vaccine and related biological
products advisory committee or verpack
are going to look at that before the fda
makes the decision
about putting this forth for an
emergency on fire
or ultimately for a license so we need
to put the rest
any concept that this was rushed in an
inappropriate way
this is really solid now
what does that mean for us we now as the
vice president said
are telling you that help is on the way
which has two aspects to it it means
that we need to actually double down on
the public health measures
right as we're waiting for that help to
come which will be soon we'll be getting
vaccine doses into people
at high priority at the end of december
we're not talking about shutting down
the country we're not talking about
locking down
we're talking about intensifying the
simple public health measures
that we all talk about mask wearing
staping distance avoiding
congregate settings doing things to the
extent that we can outdoors versus
indoors if we do that we'll be able to
hold things off
until the vaccine comes now i've used
that metaphor that the cavalry is on the
way
if you're fighting a battle and the
cavalry is on the way
you don't stop shooting you keep going
until the cavalry gets here and then you
might even want to continue
fighting and then finally one other
final thing about it
the very impressive efficacy 94.5
and 95 percent of a vaccine should
motivate individual to realize that this
is something you want to participate in
so we're going to be talking to you
about it
likely here in the future about why it's
important
as these vaccine doses roll out why we
have to do two things
continue the public health measure and
get vaccinated when the vaccine becomes
available
thank you i can see in in six weeks
coming to the podium and saying guys
get the freaking vaccine just get the
vaccine
excuse me mr vice president thank you
very much for this opportunity
so i've been asked to highlight uh our
way ahead on distribution of the vaccine
as just talked about by dr fauci and
before that
vice president pence you know we are
here today
because our mission was clear and our
mission to dr
monsef salawi my co-leader
and really heavily responsible for our
success
we are here today because we focused on
developing manufacturing and
distributing
a safe and effective vaccine and
therapeutics to the american people
our purpose is really clear save lives
and it has driven us
to this end state and that's why we're
here today
couple things as we get started in our
planning
i will tell you that the planning began
almost immediately following
our ceremony in the rose garden on 15
may that monday
we started talking development
manufacturing and distribution
it's not a thought that we've had in the
last two weeks
it's required extensive planning and
detailed work by
a collaboration of individuals which
i'll talk about
couple things we decided up front
one we were going to be able to deliver
the vaccine within 24 hours after
eua that is distribution to the entire
united states of america to include
territories and metropolitan cities
two we started with a foundation of
expertise
the cdc is the very best at planning
and executing distribution of vaccines
we took their core competency and we
aligned it with the capability
of planners project managers
and those who could run campaigns
and together this organization has come
up with our strategy for distribution
third we took the capacity of the
industry
commercial industry and we brought them
into the fold
we wanted to utilize the capability and
the capacity
that is already established in america
that has a proven track record that
knows how to distribute vaccines
that understands the nuances of ultra
cold chain
requirements we knew if we brought
pfizer moderna mckesson
ups fedex cvs walgreen
and hundreds others together that we
would come up with the best solutions
because innovation towards our end state
was our only care
it wasn't about egos and it wasn't about
credit
it was about how do we solve this
complex problem
it was clear immediately following our
initial meetings with industry
that we had to have full collaboration
to my fourth point
with the jurisdictions and the states
they had to be
a big part of our planning sequence
so together the ows cdc
industry and the states and
jurisdictions came up with the plan
that i'm going to talk to you about here
shortly it is
the effort that is almost so common
that you will recognize it because we do
it every year
we do it when we distribute influenza
vaccines
we do it when other vaccines are being
distributed the difference is
now we're pushing mass volume of a new
vaccine
and so we needed to have a strategy that
was collaborated
at all levels with all organizations in
order to execute
the last thing we needed to do was we
had to create a system to see ourselves
we had to be able to see inside of every
territory
state metropolitan city understand where
the vaccine was
from fill finish site to distribution
warehouses
down to administration sites so not only
could we maintain the flow of vaccine
but we could account for vaccine that
was being
administered that way we can keep the
flow to the american people
in a steady drumbeat as we go forward
first slide please here we go we will
distribute the vaccine accordingly
i direct you to the right side of the
slide this is our end state
this is where we want the vaccines to be
we want the vaccines down
at the places where the american people
are comfortable
at our hospitals our doctor's offices
down at cvs
walgreens down at the long care
health care facilities places where
people are comfortable going
so that's where we started end state
then we went back to pfizer and moderna
we laid out the guidelines that i gave
you these are terrible slides
of them and the commercial industry for
distribution
we came up with our plan it's relatively
simple
we take the pfizer vaccine they are
capable of distributing
on their own they will utilize fedex and
ups
in order to execute distribution
simultaneously
we will ship ancillary kits needles
syringes
alcohol wipes and the diluting required
for the vaccine
to meet the vaccine at the end state
facilities that we're talking about
for mckesson or for modern a vaccine
what we're going to do
is we're going to meet up the vaccine
with the ancillary kits
at a distribution warehouse we're going
to put them together and then we're
going to distribute through fedex
and ups down to our administration sites
strange moment okay in simple terms
we're taking it from fill finish
we're cut we're bringing together all
the requirements for administering the
vaccine
and then we're sending it down to the
distribution sites
any place that a state wants to
administer the vaccine
as long as they're enrolled what i'm
looking to hear about is
in that 24-hour period when they say
we're going to get this in people's arms
in 24 hours
who gets it is it initially simply uh
health care workers because if so
wouldn't it make more sense to send them
to the hospitals rather i mean we have
to hear about that
or we can go to ten thousand places in
the state the capability and the
capacity
exists because we came together in a
whole of america approach
it is this effort that i can look you in
the face and say to you
eua comes 24 hours later vaccines will
be distributed
out to the american people who gets it
ready for administration
to this end our mission is as i stated
safe and effective vaccines to the
american people and we need to do it in
the most timely manner possible
because it is all about lives thank you
mr rice seems like a key thing who's
getting it first the first 40 million
doses
have already done mr vice president we
already have
over a million kits of both the kits
that we'll need for the pfizer vaccine
as well as the modern vaccines
different 100 100 yeah excuse me 100
million thank you
100 million oh okay wow jesus
general carter thank you and as he said
from the time president trump announced
operation warp speed general purna and
his team
have been working literally around the
clock to build the distribution plan
that you see that's in effect
and i and i hope you all heard that i
asked him how many of those kits have
already been
manufactured for merging with um
merging with the moderna product and
they've already assembled 100 million
kits
that are ready to go and that's the
supplies that are necessary for
administering
the vaccine i i must tell you having
received my latest briefing today over
at fema
oh let anybody else talk come on can be
proud
of uh of the fact that we have a plan in
place
that the moment that the fda concludes
that that vaccine is safe and effective
we have a system in place to begin
within 24 hours
shipping that vaccines to hospitals
health care facilities
and 24 hours after that literally
injecting
uh that vaccine uh into americans
injection we'll also be continuing to
develop the prioritization working with
states
about their plans and maybe bob redfield
of cdc
so that'll be state level as well in a
moment cdc will create
a recommendation for priorities of who's
to be uh
immunized but interesting if history is
a teacher
we know that we'll focus on those most
vulnerable we'll focus on our healthcare
workers and and first responders um
at the uh at the early going but it's uh
it's it's truly inspiring to me to see
the incredible work that
operation warp speed is done and general
purna i want to thank you for uh
for your dedication with that as i said
we've continued from the very beginning
to operate an approach at the federal
level everything pence says is worthless
it's like just let the experts talk like
let's go right to redfield with the
priority list
governments are making uh in
efforts to slow the spread but
but to be very clear president trump has
been very clear that we do not support
another national lockdown and do not
believe it is necessary no one's
proposing she actually reflected again
on
we're not calling for a national
lockdown and we won't
but beyond that there have been some
actions taken in
jurisdictions around the country with
regard to closing schools
i wanted the american people to know
that it is
it is the position of this task force of
this administration and of the cdc that
we do not need
to close our schools i want to invite dr
redfield to come forward to speak about
that
but i want to emphasize what he's
reminded our task force of many times
that actually
at no point in this pandemic has the cdc
ever recommended closing schools
more we've learned about about this
virus the more it simply
affirmed that we think our kids belong
in the classroom
we're absolutely committed to continue
to provide resources
so our kids our teachers our
administrators can safely
safely get back to school but with that
let me introduce
dr redfield and with him dr eleanor
mccann's katz at hhs who
is an extraordinary leader she's going
to speak about the unintended
consequences of
just talk about the distribution
priorities around america
and um and then i'll have the secretary
i have some closing remarks oh my god dr
redfield
what an agenda
thank you mr vice president i think it's
important first for me to emphasize
what you've heard already is that we're
not defenseless
against this virus mask works
social distancing works hand washing
works
being smart about crowds particularly
indoor
works this is strategic
uses and dr burke said of testing
to identify the silent epidemic to
identify the asymptomatic infections so
that they can be
pulled out of the transmission cycle
works another point that i want to make
is that we need to follow the data we
should be making data-driven decisions
when we talk about what we're doing for
institutions
or what we're doing for commercial
closures
for example as was mentioned last spring
cdc did not recommend
school closures nor did we wreck nor did
we recommend their closures today
i will say back in the spring there was
limited data
today there's extensive data that we
have we've gathered over the last two to
three months to confirm
that k-12 schools can operate with
face-to-face
learning and they can do it safely
and they can do it responsibly the
infections that we've identified in
schools
when they've been evaluated were not
acquired in schools
they were actually inquired in the
community and in the household
today as dr burke said our big threat
for transmission is not the public
square
it's small family gatherings family
gatherings where people become
more comfortable they remove their face
mask and they get together and it's a
silent epidemic
that begins to transmit but it's not
inter-school transmission
the truth is for kids k through 12 one
of the safest place they can be
from our perspective is to remain in
school
and it's really important that
[Music]
following the data making sure we don't
make emotional
decisions about what to close
this is excruciating i agree with you
guys i'm here to say clearly the data
strongly supports that k-12 schools
as well as institutes of higher learning
really are not where we're having our
challenges and it would be
counterproductive from my point of view
from a public health point of view just
in containing the epidemic
if there was an emotional response to
say let's close the schools
finally you know i wanted to echo
what has been said by the vice president
and dr fauci
is we are seeing the light at the end of
the tunnel
where we are to now and this is why now
more than ever
as was said by dr burks and dr fauci
myself
now more than ever we're asking all
americans
all americans to redouble their
efforts to be vigilant to embrace mass
social distancing
hand washing our advice about about
crowds and really to support
um using the data
to make decisions in their communities
particularly as relates to
k-12s and institutes of higher learning
these clearly the data support that it's
really important from public health
perspective both from the pandemic
as well as what we'll you'll hear about
in a minute
that these schools stay open finally i
just want to
end on a clear message of confidence
that i'm confident that we're going to
emerge
successful and bring this pandemic to an
end
i don't have any doubt in that oh okay
but today
we need we need all of us to go
all in we'll go all in with
face coverings social distancing hand
washing smartness about
crowds doing our part to help identify
the silent epidemic
and i have confidence that at the end of
the day we're going to get
a very achievable goal which is to get
this pandemic under control
thank you mr vice president
so now she'll advocate for keeping
schools open
thank you mr vice president in my role
as assistant secretary for mental health
and substance use
i feel very strongly about the need to
protect and promote the mental health of
all americans
as a psychiatrist i'm continually
thinking about the mental health effects
of this
unprecedented situation and how best to
mitigate the impact
individuals across our country are
living with stress
that they have likely never experienced
we must find a way
to best alleviate that stress without
ignoring the fact
that our nation faces a very real and
deadly virus
i often think about this in the context
of our country's children
i leave the substance abuse and mental
health services administration or samhsa
which is the only federal agency whose
primary charge is addressing
mental and substance use disorders
across the country
where better to start in addressing this
challenge than with our nation's young
people
protecting and also fostering the social
and emotional well-being of children
she really is terrible when trump did
one of these roundtables at the white
house with like a you know a huge
it was actually a square table round
table um
she was like in the back she wasn't even
allowed at the table she was in the back
and they had her stand up and just talk
about
you know open schools open it we just we
just don't need this at this point you
know we're almost at thanksgiving
then you've got winter break we we did
this is not you know let states decide
what makes sense new york city has
closed schools
this is totally uh useless cannot be
overstated
however we also cannot overstate the
need to address the fear
uncertainty and safety considerations
with returns to school
i understand that parents and teachers
may feel great anxiety
that is why we must put into place the
safety measures we know work
we must use masks we must enforce social
distancing
this delivery is a little bit odd too
but creative and innovative ways to
limit the number of children and
teachers in the building at any given
time
there are tools we have and we must
think through how best to use
them to keep our schools open thank you
very much
we know that over 7.4 million children
in this country
live with serious emotional disturbances
and over
60 percent receive services from the
school system
we know that children with disabilities
are losing ground with the closure of
schools
we know that millions of children across
the country are experiencing child abuse
and neglect
that goes undetected due to lack of
contact with school personnel
who serve as mandatory reporters we must
work together to address these issues
i believe strongly that we need schools
to open in communities whose data
indicate it's safe to do so
but we cannot forget the protection of
our teachers and school staff
if they don't feel it's safe to return
to work
it will not help to open schools we must
ensure that teachers
school staff and parents are engaged in
the solutions
that we ultimately choose just as i'm
suggesting
that we engage our teachers i suggest
also that we recognize the very real
mental health considerations of what you
may have heard
called pandemic fatigue uh-oh the
engagement
of americans all over the country and
slowing the spread of the virus is a
strategy i think we should all consider
again we know masks work but we know
that some americans aren't sure and may
not be as compliant
as we'd like well tell them the truth
for local officials
but rather than punishing or sanctioning
what if we employ a different technique
what if we recognize the psychological
aspects of the fatigue and try to
reinforce positive behavior
with rewards with rewards rather than
solely sanction what we deem to be bad
behavior
for example we know that compliance on
college campuses has been a challenge
and individuals in this age group are a
potential source of spread
what if college has implemented a random
reward system for mask wearing
this could be as simple as implementing
a small gift card being given out to a
student wearing a mask
this technique known as contingency
management has had great success
in the behavioral health care treatment
getting weird
i offer it as a consideration which
acknowledges the psychological aspects
of our life's changes
i want to conclude by saying that the
physical effects of coronavirus are very
real
and this virus has brought along with
its stress anxiety
and fear that you may have never felt
before
covet 19 has brought devastating loss of
life to families across the nation
in addition to those who have lost lives
to the infection itself
there are those of you who have what i
call
covet related deaths in your family
these are not deaths by
infection but death by suicide
or death by drug overdose during this
pandemic
please know that we have not forgotten
you or your loss
your loss is great and my job is to do
all i can to prevent additional families
from experiencing that loss
to the parents and teachers who are
afraid and confused
that fear and anxiety is real and it's
stressful
to the people who are without a job and
unsure of your next steps
your stress is real too the stress of
this situation can often feel too great
to handle and we take very sick this is
all true and important
i i just find it weird to kind of
crowbar it
into this briefing um
i just am unsure but these are important
messages
open and ready to serve as you struggle
with these great stressors especially
during the holiday season
please try to stay connected to loved
ones
please reach out to friends and family
and please know that samhsa's national
suicide prevention lifeline is available
to help at any time at
all we can 800-273-8255 protect it thank
you very much
and then i think next we will hear from
alex azar yes there we go
he is quite a sycophant let's see thank
you mr vice president
good to see all of you the doctors have
well covered the serious state of the
epidemiological
evidence that we have and they've talked
about the steps that we can and should
be taking
but they've also talked about the steps
that aren't evidence-based
that we should not be taking right now
we are much better prepared today than
we were months ago
general sanford talked about our ppe
supplies
our ventilator supplies the vice
president talked about our expanded
testing capacity nationwide reach of
over 120 million tests available in the
month of november alone
70 million of them point-of-care tests
we've improved dramatically our quality
of care in our hospitals our ability to
treat people
who suffer from covet my message to the
american people
is to hang in there with us take the
simple steps
that the doctors have talked about today
because there is light at the end of the
tunnel
this isn't forever thanks to president
trump's operation warp speed
we've got such a brighter future ahead
and i want to see everyone get there
president trump called me in and said
alex
all the experts are saying it's going to
be optimistically 18 months for a
vaccine
president trump called me in and said
alex why does it always smell that way
when you walk into my office
could we shorten that is there anything
we could do and i said yes there is
and we crafted the greatest
biopharmaceutical research development
manufacturing distribution
mobilization and partnership with the
defense department with the
constant personal unwavering support of
president trump
this guy is the worst results on that
this is thanks to the leadership people
people like general purna running
operation warp speed bringing the
complete logistics and operations and
procurement power of the defense
department to the table
and it's thanks to people like dr monsef
slawy
probably the world's greatest vaccine
developer who's dedicated his complete
life and talents
to this work for the american people and
we're seeing the results
they said it couldn't be done but 10
months
into this novel pathogen hitting our
shores
last week we approved eli lilly's
monoclonal antibody
we shipped product that very afternoon
to patients
and already over sixty thousand courses
of therapy
have been delivered regeneron's
combination monoclonal antibody
is pending at the fda right now
as we've talked about over the last two
weeks we've seen just unprecedented
historic
news about vaccines two vaccines
each with 95 percent efficacy
rivaling the 98 percent efficacy
of our measles vaccine produced in some
of the largest
vaccine clinical trials ever conducted
in history over 40
000 patients in each of these clinical
trials
demonstrating good safety profiles
this was done in 10 10 months 10
months and now pfizer's partner bioentec
has announced that tomorrow they intend
to file
for emergency use authorization at the
fda
tomorrow we would expect to see moderna
filing soon also
we also have this comprehensive
distribution plan that general purnell
walked through
that builds on the public-private
partnership between the united states
and these incredible private sector
partners with a goal to make the
distribution of this vaccine as
convenient to you as the flu vaccine is
and working in partnership with our
states because the states know the
situation on the ground
and we work to support them and we will
ship
millions of doses of vaccine within 24
hours of fda approval
so my message is hope and help are on
the way
operation warp speed is already
delivering and it's going to keep
delivering in the days and weeks
ahead thank you very much mr vice
president thank you very much alex
let me say i my hope is that uh
americans looking on and all of you
responsible for sharing the news
and know that this team
working in cooperation with our states
with the cooperation of the american
people
has made great progress and we're
getting there
we're getting there america and as i
said at the outset
does pence take questions and if so how
many of them are
did you lose the election sir supplies
that are available today for our
hospitals our ability to track
what's happening at your local hospital
to make sure it has the ppe and the
equipment and supplies to provide the
health care
that your family may need i hope
i hope as you heard about the
extraordinary distribution plans
of operation warp speed and the
confidence
of that dr fauci expressed today and the
news that
one of those research companies is going
to submit an emergency use authorization
tomorrow on the very first
vaccine that we are literally literally
we could well be just a matter of a few
short weeks away from a vaccine being
available
across this country for the most
vulnerable among us and for those that
are caring for them in our hospitals
and our clinics i hope everything you've
heard today gives evidence of what i
said at the start that america has never
been more prepared to combat this virus
but let me be clear as i close we all
have a role to play
in the days ahead and you heard this
team say as we uh
as we see that finish line as you see
light finish lines coming quick for this
administration
and you should see evidence here that we
are rounding the corner to that day that
we have a vaccine
for the american people we do want to
encourage every american to continue to
do your part
wash your hands practice social
distancing
wear a mask when social distancing isn't
possible
do your part to put the health of your
family the health of your neighbors to
help the people in your community first
we are all in this together and as i've
said many times from this podium over
many many months
i know that with the cooperation of the
american people with our incredible
doctors and nurses and first responders
with the extraordinary partnership of
federal and state and local health
officials
uh and with god's help we will get
through this
what and we will get through this
together vice president
did you win the election mr vice
president will you admit you didn't win
anyway so there's that wow what an event
what a day what a day what a day what a
day let's listen to that again
oh my god what an absolute and complete
mess
um thanks everybody for joining me um
we will be continuing to cover these
events if we ever hear from donald trump
again and i don't i don't know
if we will uh i will certainly be with
you please make sure if you are watching
on youtube on the way out hit that
subscribe button
it it costs you nothing it just pushes
the algorithm a little bit
to maybe recommend a video or two to you
in the future hit that subscribe button
if you're watching on twitch
please hit the follow button we are very
very strongly trying to get to 100 000
twitch followers
and if you're watching on facebook hit
that like button i will see everybody
again
very very soon